seven days later
i'm out of quarantine mask on
oh i forgot what the fresh air was like
hello world i'm here
i can't even get on the plane without a
mask obviously
but i also need my hand sanitizer
gloves who's that they are
[Music]
the coronavirus is everywhere you look
very empty airports
tons of travel advisories telling you to
stay six feet apart
[Music]
okay so right now we are on the disney
campus but we aren't
in the bubble area in the confined area
where players our staff is so we're
headed there now
[Music]
hey guys taylor rex here i am in orlando
to cover the nba restart
mask on ready to go let's do it
hey spencer what's up not much how you
been
hey rudy hey yo kimba what up
what's goodie what's up goodie how you
doing i've been good in the bubble
living you know my like double beds i
don't know why we all have two
full beds in here even though it's just
us like it's it's weird but i am
enjoying my hotel room i have no
complaints i mean your icon so they want
to make sure the accommodations were
just perfect
all the health check that you'll need
for your stay here okay
[Music]
one thing i do to pass the time is i
love games
uh kawhi leonard's team
clifford los angeles yup yup yup
99 best dunker of all time best time for
all time
dominique no no no no no best knocker
best knocker ah
vince carter
whenever you go downstairs you're going
to see somebody
like the other night like me and jt was
walking to get some food and we've seen
braun jr jared dudley
it's rare it's very rare to see braun
walking by himself and being comfortable
like i was telling somebody he probably
haven't
done that since he was probably nine
years old you know like
being able to be so comfortable just
walking around not worried about people
coming up to him being bothered asking
for something
you know he's able to you know be
comfortable and walk around comfortably
so
i think that's pretty cool
lunchtime you were to abide by all
dietary restrictions taylor rooks no
beef
no pork look at today's bubble dessert a
cupcake
i have to report what this number is
apparently it should always be between
like 95 and 100 so right now my pulse is
doing well 99.1
and how are you feeling obviously i know
you or somebody who
tested positive for coronavirus at one
point how do you feel now it hit me kind
of hard the first several days and then
it was just a really weird up and down
type of thing it was kind of like the
flu but
if it was like better and then not
better and it wasn't
you know a finite timeline than just
good you know what i mean so
that that's what was most weird about it
even though i had that
symptom uh just that day
i just you know i was kind of like in
disbelief for
for a second and then i was just like
okay i have it
you know so so i obviously got to
orlando sunday um
july 12th we were tested on sunday
monday i get a phone call saying that my
test was positive
um yeah they said i would just like keep
getting tested until i have two negative
tests and then
and then i'd be cleared i'm asymptomatic
and
all that stuff so fingers crossed
girl i do not want to have it
is this breaking news let me finish the
story they tested me
and i was positive but then they re-ran
that same test from the same sample they
took from me and i was negative
yeah it's crazy and then i was tested
again
yesterday night they aren't allowing us
to record
um a carotid virus test but i just got
mine it's a
nasal swab here here and then a mouth
swab
and i just got the results back i is
tested negative
for coronavirus i have two negative
carbon virus tests
your girl ain't got the rona
okay i am clear to enter into the
orlando campus
baby i can tell that john moran is bored
here in florida because we have been
playing
games on our phones this whole time
that was a bad move by you job man moved
by you
it's like do i want to kill you slow or
do i want to kill you quick you know
what i'm saying i got it
so then i'm gonna get a chance to win
right there
[Music]
i have to record this because lunch
today is very good we got some chicken
parm
[Music]
now that you are here harder or easier
than you thought this is nothing
this is nothing yeah this is i'm having
a i'm having a great time i'm keeping
honest with you
we are here for a reason to get on the
court
and of course you know we got a lot of
time on the court and we try to fill
those gaps with
not spending time together you know we
all like to do
on the side but you know we are here for
for one thing you know
to play basketball love having a bunch
of
negative tests here's my false positive
and they have all been negative since
hello world
i'm here